- [Instructor] In other
videos, we have talked
about how the other branches
of government can limit
Supreme Court powers.
We're going to continue that
conversation in this video
by discussing how the
amendment process can
also limit or overrule a
Supreme Court decision,
so let's go to 1875.
Just for some context, the 14th Amendment,
the United States, had
already been ratified,
and in particular, you have the Privileges
or Immunities Clause of the 14th Amendment
that says no state shall
make or enforce any law
which shall abridge the
privileges or immunities
of citizens of the United States.
Well, you could imagine a
lot of women at the time
who were citizens of the
United States said that,
"Look, voting is a privilege
of being a citizen,
"but I am not allowed to vote,"
and so you have Virginia Minor,
who was a citizen in Missouri,
decides to register to vote.
She is denied and eventually
takes the registrar to court.
It eventually gets appealed all the way
to the United States Supreme Court
in Minor versus Happersett,
where Happersett is the
registrar in Missouri,
and the Supreme Court in this case rules
that voting is not a privilege
of citizenship for women,
and it seems absurd to us right now,
that voting seems to be one
of the main privileges of being a citizen,
but that's the way the
Supreme Court ruled in 1875.
Now, the folks who were
fighting for a women's right
to vote weren't just women.
They were also men, eventually started
to have victories in the
early 1900s at various states,
especially states in the
West, started to allow women
to vote, but as we go into
the teens of the 1900s,
the movement gets enough
steam to get Congress
and the state legislators to propose
and ratify the 19th Amendment,
which says the right of
citizens of the United States
to vote shall not be denied or abridged
by the United States or by
any state on account of sex.
Congress shall have power
to enforce this article by
appropriate legislation.
So what we have here is
the legislative branch,
both the U.S. Congress and
the state legislatures,
because it needs to be voted
for by 2/3 of both houses
of Congress and then ratified
by 3/4 of the states,
they essentially overruled the Minor
versus Happersett decision.
They said, "All right, Supreme Court.
"You might see some ambiguity
in the 14th Amendment,"
although today it's hard to say
that voting isn't a
privilege of citizenship,
but to make it very clear, they proposed
and ratified the 19th Amendment.
So not only is this an interesting time
in American history.
Not that long ago, less than
100 years before this video
that I'm making was made, women
did not have the full right
to vote most of the United States.
We eventually get the 19th Amendment,
but above and beyond
that, this is an example
of how other branches of
government can exercise some checks
on the Unites States Supreme Court.